did we really all need to go to saddle
ranch that badly that like we couldn't
have
waited for the deathly pandemic to pass
yeah so that was ariana grande throwing
some
very specific shade at influencers in la
who have been going out amid the
coronavirus
pandemic it was like so crazy and
tick-tock stars dixie dimlio and addison
wray
heard ari's message loud and clear yeah
it's crazy
ari recently appeared on the zack saying
show to promote her new album positions
and opened up about her frustrations
with people not taking the coronavirus
pandemic
seriously couldn't we have just stayed
at home for a few more weeks like all
the other countries that were fine
and are better than we are that's when
she zeroed in
on influencers in la did we really all
need to go to
saddle ranch that badly that like we
couldn't have
waited for the deathly pandemic to pass
like we all really needed to put on our
cowgirl boots and ride a mechanical bull
that bad
we all did that instagram post that
badly
okay so she didn't name names but some
of tick tock's biggest stars have been
known to hang out at the la hot spot
in fact addison and her on-again
off-again boyfriend bryce hall
even partied there together on halloween
well
on monday the 20 year old was asked
about ari's shade while out and about in
la with bryce
her response quote i think it's fair i
definitely have been not going because
i've been working out a lot and
also preparing for my movie now that is
a classic hollywood answer
of course that movie she's working on is
the upcoming gender swap remake
of she's all that i'll pick the girl and
you got six weeks to turn her into the
prom queen
and get this addison who has more than
67 million followers on tick tock
added that she wants her man to stay
home too quote
no more parties for bryce we love each
other so much and like we love being
around each other and
we're super good friends that same
outlet also chatted with dixie demilio
she admitted ari has a good point quote
she's right she's right she's a queen
love her
oh thank you of course tick-tock stars
aren't the only ones under fire for
partying it up amid the coronavirus
pandemic
kendall jenner recently made headlines
for her halloween-themed
25th birthday bash in la tons of famous
faces were in attendance like her
sisters kylie jenner and kim and
kourtney kardashian
the weeknd justin bieber dogecat winnie
harlow
and jaden smith just to name a few
e.t has learned that every person
entering the venue both employees
and guests had to have a rapid covet
test with a negative result before going
into the party